let's talk about the liver and some
really important things you can do
to help improve your ability to detoxify
and
reverse damage to the liver now i have
personal experience
with having a very damaged liver and
some people will ask me well did you
cure your liver right well i have no
residual symptoms from it and i seem to
have resolved my liver problems but if i
go
off my plan okay just a little bit i
will start to experience symptoms of a
liver problem and the reason i'm
bringing that up is because sometimes
when people will have this idea that
if you cure something you can then go
back to your
normal diet or your regular diet and be
able to tolerate some of those foods for
example let's take diabetes i had
someone actually ask me this
well
will your diet
fix my diabetes
so i can then go back to my regular plan
i'm like
no you can't do that because that would
be equivalent to having a car that runs
on
unleaded
now you're going to switch to diesel and
think that your car is going to run
normal if you put diesel in an engine
that's not designed for diesel okay and
you ruin it
you can't go back to diesel okay you
have to use the fuel that that car is
designed to run on the same thing with
the body our bodies were meant to run on
ketone fuel any glucose that it needs it
can make very very easily and this
especially applies to the liver if you
overload the liver with too much glucose
or carbs
it's not going to work right so the
liver needs certain things to function
okay but what i want to talk about
is something a little bit different
and that is glutathione glutathione is
one of the most important antioxidants
for your liver and pretty much for all
your cells all your cells have
glutathione in it in very very large
quantities and it's very important i
like to call it a superhero because it's
there to
protect the liver it's there to help
repair the liver from damage and there's
a lot of research on glutathione there's
actually over a hundred thousand
uh peer review papers in scientific
journals
just on glutathione so it's well
researched and so it's heavily involved
with the repair actions of the liver as
well as the detoxification function of
your liver and so whether you have a
fatty liver or an inflamed liver or scar
tissue or cirrhosis of the liver
maintaining your glutathione levels is
going to be a very very important thing
to do now as far as detoxification
glutathione has
special affinity for heavy metals okay
especially mercury it pulls it out of
the brain
and brings it to the liver and out
through the bile and it gets it out of
the body i mean that's like miraculous
it helps to change
poisons that are fat soluble
that are stuck in the body to
water-soluble harmless particles that's
that's pretty cool it helps to break
down things like hydrogen peroxide that
your cells make
as one of the defense mechanisms in the
immune system
your body makes a lot of hydrogen
peroxide so glutathione comes in there
and helps to
neutralize that if you have overdosed on
something called acetaminophen then
glutathione could come in there and
neutralize that effect
if you drink a lot of alcohol
glutathione can help
minimize the damage to your liver if you
are taking medications on a regular
basis
you should be making sure your
glutathione is at a higher level i mean
there are so many health conditions that
are connected to low levels of
glutathione there's over 75 major
diseases that are associated with low
glutathione levels and the problem is as
we age we make less and less of it so
i'm going to talk about how to keep it
at a higher level on your body it can
also improve
insulin resistance it can help counter
exercise fatigue and it can protect the
mitochondria that's one of its main
functions
the mitochondria is all about producing
energy and when you get damage in the
mitochondria you're more susceptible to
getting cancer and so glutathione is
directly involved in keeping the
mitochondria from becoming too damaged
so you can prevent cancer so it's a
really important molecule all right so
how do we become depleted with
glutathione well number one we get older
okay number two
trauma the more trauma you have
the less glutathione you're gonna have
and so the need for glutathione goes up
the problem is when you get traumatized
you end up in the hospital right
and then where do they feed you
all the things that deplete glutathione
so that's not good so
junk food
conventional foods deplete glutathione
alcohol depletes glutathione stress
depletes glutathione toxins exposure to
heavy metals plastics chemicals
medications drugs all deplete
glutathione and increase the need for
glutathione over training let's say you
go to the gym and you exercise too much
now you end up with
low amounts of glutathione
and of course
being a pre-diabetic a diabetic or
eating a lot of carbohydrates especially
refined carbohydrates sugars can deplete
your glutathione levels
so the question is how
do we beef up this number no pun
intended well just so happens that beef
is loaded with glutathione so eating
beef is a good thing and eating animal
products will give you more glutathione
than
plant sources however plant sources will
also give you glutathione especially the
ones that are high in sulfur okay that
would be like the cruciferous family of
vegetables um kale broccoli brussels
sprouts radishes especially now other
sulfur vegetables like garlic onion
very very good to increase your
glutathione and so when you have your
animal meats like whether you have your
beef or your fish or whatever
add the garlic and onion to it to really
optimize
that glutathione now there's other
supplements you can take to increase
your glutathione as well nac is one
alpha lipoic acid is another curcumin
which is from turmeric is another
vitamin d
will help you
sami is another and melatonin and i'm
not talking about the supplement
melatonin i'm just talking about
the melatonin that you can get from
being exposed to infrared light so being
out in the sun will increase melatonin
which will then increase glutathione and
melatonin is a very powerful antioxidant
as well so the combination is really
good and also what the sun will do for
your stress it lowers your stress levels
and so all these things together can
compound
this amazing effect to increase
glutathione but i think it's important
to understand
the mechanics of glutathione so you can
understand that if you
were traumatized for example you have an
injury well definitely start getting
more glutathione to counter that effect
or let's say you slipped off your
program and drank some alcohol well now
beef up your glutathione levels
or you know you're you're aging the
older you get the more stressed you are
the more that you have to take
medications the more important is
to keep your diet really really clean
to increase your glutathione to counter
and neutralize the effect
that these things can have on your body
now there's a lot more to know about the
liver and so i want you to watch this
video next i put it up here check it out
you